and hoping that wall would be here the  trade came up and  drew up maybe you disagree but i think  hindsight might be 20 20 but  you still make that trade every time  yeah i mean  it was an untradeable contract you got  to remember two weeks  before it actually uh actually went down  so it wasn't an untradable contract it  was a tradable contract  but um the way it all went down i think  it could have been done better  but when is a trade  ever go smoothly with the emotions he uh  involved on both sides westbrook  and now double technicals  [Applause]  talking about emotions being involved  these are the two guys that got traded  for each other  neil comes in to try to settle things  down  westbrook is hot right now  [Applause]  honestly i hope it fires westbrook